♪
>> PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU
INFORMED ME THAT ISRAEL HAS
AGREED TO A MUTUAL UNCONDITIONAL
CEASE-FIRE TO BEGIN IN LESS THAN
TWO HOURS.
THE EGYPTIANS HAVE NOW INFORMED
US THAT HAMAS AND THE OTHER
GROUPS IN GAZA HAVE ALSO AGREED.
THE UNITED STATES FULLY SUPPORTS
ISRAEL'S TRITE DEFEND ITSELF
AGAINST INDISCRIMINATE ROCKET
ATTACKS ON HAMAS AND OTHER
GAZA-BASED TERRORIST GROUPS.
I ASSURED HIM MY FULL SUPPORT TO
REPLENISH ISRAEL'S IRON DOME
SYSTEM TO ENSURE ITS DEFENSES
AND SECURITY IN THE FUTURE.
>> Shannon: BRING IN THE PANEL
TO READ THE LATEST REMARKS AND
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
CONTINETTI, MARA LIASSON
NATIONAL POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
OF "NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO."
AND TREY GOWDY FORMER
CONGRESSMAN FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU.
TREY, I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S REMARKS TODAY?
HE HAS FACED A LOT OF PRESSURE
FROM THE PROGRESSIVE MORE
LEFTIST PART OF HIS PARTY
INCLUDING MEMBERS ON THE HILL
WHO DON'T WANT HIM TO BE SO FULL
THROAT OF HIS DEFENSE OF ISRAEL
OUR ALLY IN THAT REGION.
>> YEAH, CERTAINLY A REPUDIATION
OF THAT WING OF THE PARTY.
THERE IS BERNIE SANDERS AOC AND
OTHERS ARE HAVING THE DIFFICULT
TIME TELLING THE TERRORISTS FROM
OUR ALLIES.
THIS IS A REPUDIATION OF THAT
WING OF THE PARTY.
I'M GLAD HE TALKED TO NETANYAHU.
I HOPE HE IS ALSO GOING TO SEND
A MESSAGE TO HAMAS AND TO IRAN.
WHAT'S EVEN BETTER THAN A
CEASE-FIRE, SHANNON IS NOT TO
NEED A CEASE-FIRE.
TELL THEM TO STOP FIRING ROCKETS
INTO ISRAEL AND THEN WE WON'T
NEED THE CEASE-FIRE.
>> Shannon: THE PRESIDENT ALSO
SAID THEY WILL WORK ON A NUMBER
OF THINGS GETTING HUMANITARIAN
AID IN AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND REBUILDING GAZA WHICH HAS
OBVIOUSLY HAD A LOT OF
DESTRUCTION THE LAST 11 DAYS OR
SO.
BUT HE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY WANT TO WORK WITH
THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY, NOT
HAMAS, MARA, IT SOUNDS LIKE HE
IS TRYING TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY WHO IS AT FAULT
HERE AND WHO WE INTEND TO WORK
WITH MOVING FORWARD.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT IS
REALLY CLEAR.
IT UNDERMINES THE REPUBLICAN
TALKING POINTS THAT SOMEHOW HE
IS CONTROLLED BY THE LEFT WING
OF HIS PARTY OR HE DOES TOO MUCH
TO CATER TO THEM.
THIS IS PRETTY CLEAR.
HE WANTS TO WORK WITH THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY.
NOT HAMAS.
IS HE GOING TO HELP ISRAEL
REPLENISH IRON DOME, ITS DEFENSE
SYSTEM THAT SEEMS TO HAVE WORKED
PRETTY WELL AGAINST HAMAS
ROCKETS.
SO HE KNOW WHERE HE STANDS IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
HE DID WORK FOR THE CEASE-FIRE,
PEOPLE CRITICIZED HIM FOR NOT
COMING OUT AND CALLING.
THE SENATE WERE CALLING FOR ONE
BUT IT WAS PRETTY CLEAR THAT JOE
BIDEN, LIKE OTHER AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS BEFORE HIM DID NOT
WANT TO CALL FOR A CEASE-FIRE
BEFORE ISRAEL WAS READY TO
ENGAGE IN ONE BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO BE LEFT LOOKING
LIKE THEY HAD NO LEVERAGE AT ALL
WITH THE ISRAELI GOVERNMENT.
BUT I THINK, YOU KNOW, WE NOW
KNOW WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS, I'M
SURE THE PROGRESSIVE WING OF HIS
PARTY ISN'T THRILLED ABOUT IT.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S THE KIND
OF RIFT THAT'S GOING TO SPILL
OVER INTO OTHER DOMESTIC ISSUES.
>> Shannon: WELL, THEY HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THE SQUAD MEMBERS
IN PARTICULAR, WE THINK ABOUT
THEM, BUT THEY ARE CALLING FOR
THIS STOPPING OF WEAPONRY AND
FUNDING TO ISRAEL.
THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY CLEAR AS
MARA MENTIONED ABOUT
REPLENISHING THE IRON DOME AND
HOW CRITICAL THAT HAS BEEN TO
PROTECTING THE PEOPLE OF ISRAEL.
MATTHEW, I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING FROM TWO DIFFERENT
SIDES OF THE AISLE IN THE SENATE
ABOUT HOW THIS IS BEING VIEWED
ON CAPITOL HILL AND BEYOND.
>> I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
MOURNING THE LOSS OF ISRAELI
LIFE BUT WE SHOULD ALSO BE
MOURNING THE LOSS OF PALESTINIAN
LIFE.
OR PERHAPS SOME PEOPLE THINK
THAT PALESTINIAN LIVES DON'T
MATTER.
I WOULD HOPE NOT.
>> I THINK IT IS SHAMEFUL THAT
THE RADICAL LEFT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS CHOOSING
THIS MOMENT TO TRY TO UNDERMINE
OUR FRIEND AND ALLY, THE NATION
OF ISRAEL AND TO SUPPORT HAMAS.
THE TWO ARE NOT MORALLY
EEQUIVALENT.
>> Shannon: MATTHEW, IT FEELS
LIKE SO MANY OF THE
CONVERSATIONS AND DISPUTES
HAPPENING ON CAPITOL HILL AND
MORE BROADLY IN WASHINGTON COME
BACK TO THESE SEMANTIC GAMES
ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE REALLY MEAN,
WHAT THEIR INTENTIONS ARE WHAT
DO YOU MAKE ABOUT HOW THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE IS PLAYING ON
CAPITOL HILL?
>> I THINK SOMEONE NEEDS TO
EXPLAIN TO SENATOR SANDERS THAT
IT WAS HAMAS WHO INITIATED THE
VIOLENCE BY FIRING ROCKETS
INDISCRIMINATELY AT ISRAEL'S
CIVILIAN POPULATION.
IT'S HAMAS THAT CONTROLS GAZA
UNDEMOCRATICALLY SINCE IT SEIZED
CONTROL IN 2007 FROM FATAH.
IT'S HAMAS ELM BEDS
INFRASTRUCTURE CIVILIAN
POPULATION IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE
CIVILIAN IMAWCIALTS OF ITS OWN
PEOPLE.
IT'S HAMAS IN YOUR OWN CLIP WITH
TREY YINGST WAS FIRING ON
HUMANITARIAN AID.
WE NEED TO BE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR,
SHANNON, IT'S HAMAS' CONFLICT
MUCH THE REASON THAT THE
CEASE-FIRE IS GOOD NEWS IS THAT
IT SINGLES THAT ISRAEL IS
CONFIDENT THAT IT DESTROYED
ENOUGH OF HAMAS' INFRASTRUCTURE
TO AT LEAST STOP THE ROCKET
ATTACKS FOR SOME AMOUNT OF TIME.
>> Shannon: THE PRIME MINISTER
AND DEFENSE MINISTER THERE IN
ISRAEL CLEAR THAT WAS THE GOAL
AND THEY WOULD CONTINUE UNTIL
THEY FELT THEY HAD MADE THAT
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENT.
TO A MUCH LESS HEATED BATTLE BUT
ONE THAT IS POLITICAL AND
GROWING HERE DOMESTICALLY IS
THIS FIGHT ON CAPITOL HILL OVER
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IN LIGHT OF
THE CDC'S CONVERSATION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN RECENT DAYS
MANDATING THAT MASKS STILL BE
WORN ON THE HOUSE FLOOR WHEN
MEMBERS ARE THERE TO SPEAK.
HERE IS THE BACK AND FORTH FROM
THE TWO SIDES OVER THAT.
>> ATTENDING PHYSICIAN AND
THAT'S THE GUIDANCE WE HAVE TO
GO BY SAID UNLESS PEOPLE ARE
VACCINATED WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO WEAR MAVERICKS IN OUR
MEETINGS AND ON THE FLOOR.
>> WE ARE REQUIRED TO WEAR A
MASK ON THE HOUSE FLOOR AND IN
THE COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
IRONICALLY, THAT'S WHERE THE TV
CAMERAS ARE.
THIS IS PURELY THEATER.
>> APPARENTLY COVID WORKS
DIFFERENTLY IN BOTH CHAMBERS.
IN THE SENATE YOU DON'T WEAR A
MASK.
IN THE HOUSE YOU HAVE TO WEAR
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THE
SPEAKER.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO ABIDE BY THE
CDC RULES.
SHE ACTUALLY WANTS TO HAVE
GREATER CONTROL.
>> Shannon: TREY, I SUSPECT THIS
IS ONE OF THESE THINGS THAT
MAKES YOU NOT MISS BEING ON
CAPITOL HILL IN THE HOUSE.
>> ONE OF A TRILLION.
SHANNON, THERE WERE A LOT OF
RULES WHEN I WAS IN THE HOUSE.
AND THEY WERE USUALLY HONORED
ONLY IN THEIR BREACH.
WE WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO BRING
DRINKS ON THE HOUSE FLOOR.
WE WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO TAKE
PICTURES.
ALMOST EVERYONE VIOLATED THOSE.
I DID NOT.
I'M A RULE FOLLOWER WHICH KIND
OF BRINGS ME TO MY LARGER POINT.
ANYONE CAN FOLLOW A RULE THEY
AGREE WITH.
I MEAN, IT TAKES NO COURAGE TO
FOLLOW A RULE YOU AGREE WITH.
IT'S THOSE THAT WE DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT SEPARATES THE LAW AND
ORDER PEOPLE FROM EVERYONE ELSE.
SO, IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE RULE,
THEN RETAKE THE HOUSE AND CHANGE
THE RULES OR HONOR IT OR IF YOU
ARE GOING TO BREAK IT AND ENGAGE
IN CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE PAY YOUR
DOGGONE FINE.
THOSE ARE YOUR THREE OPTIONS.
HONOR THE RULE, CHANGE THE RULE
OR ENGAGE IN CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE
BUT PAY YOUR FINE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DO SO.
>> Shannon: I BET I'M NOT THE
ONLY ONE STILL USING THE PHRASE
DADGUM.
USED NICELY THERE, TREY.
WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE SAYING THEY
WILL PAY THE FINE.
WHAT ABOUT THE ACCUSATION FOR
MEMBERS ONLY IN TV CAMERA RANGE
THAT THE MASKS ARE MANDATED?
>> IT'S OBVIOUS THIS IS
POLITICAL ON PELOSI'S PART.
SHE WANTS TO PUNISH THE MEMBERS,
MAINLY REPUBLICANS WHO HAVEN'T
TAKEN THE VACCINE WHEN, IN FACT,
THEY ARE ONLY ENDANGERING
THEMSELVES BY NOT HAVING THE
VACCINATION.
IT'S VERY POLITICIZED AND
PARTISAN AND ONLY PROVES TO ME,
SHANNON, THERE IS NO CURE FOR
NANCY PELOSI'S SILLINESS.
>> Shannon: ALL RIGHT, MARA,
GIVE US THE FINAL WORD ON THIS.
>> FINAL WORD IS THE CDC SAYS IF
YOU ARE FULLY VACCINATED YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WEAR A MASK INSIDE
OR OUT.
>> Shannon: ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL LEAVE IT THERE.
PANEL, THANK